charity is in Illinois I am only in my
30s but my parents are getting older
that generally happens my siblings and I
are looking into purchasing long-term
care insurance for one or both of them I
know you say that everyone should
purchase long-term care insurance is
sixty but if a person is in good health
would waiting until closer to 70 be a
good idea additionally does it actually
cover everything needed for long-term
care about 70% if you get a good policy
it covers in-home care as well as
nursing home care and about 70% of the
policies right now the claims that are
going out or for in-home care and so
that covers quote-unquote everything
that doesn't cover your medical it
covers the nursing home or the in-home
care that's the equivalent and so you
know that that's what it does cover now
typically most you know the very few
people spend very much time in a nursing
home and most of these policies cover
only about three years which is plenty
to be truthful because of the way the
thing is set up it you know it just
doesn't you know the average time spent
on nursing homes two point four years
and they cover three years and the
percentage that stayed longer than three
years is only 1/4 of the people and so
that's what you're looking at and so you
want three to four years maybe five
years in coverage you want a in-home
care type of a benefit and most of these
are a three to a $5,000 per month
benefit and that's what they cover so if
you doesn't cover everything know if you
sign up for a $6,000 a month nursing
home and you have a $3,000 benefit it
doesn't so you know you pick a nursing
home or in-home care that is within the
amount of coverage and that's what it
does so if you wanna learn more what you
need to do sit down with a good
independent agent that will shop among
several different companies and get you
the best
and no I would not wait until 70 if
there is a need once their 60 if people
can afford it I don't want you to start
the death and I want you going into dad
I don't want you not paying off debt or
something like that because you're
buying a long-term care policy for your
parents but you know learn about it look
about it not don't panic about it but I
would not wait until 70 it's not a
better deal if everybody's healthy
because it's not generally the way the
thing works so the statistics are the
75% of the ladies will outlive their
husbands and so the normal scenario is
Papa goes into the nursing home they've
saved $300,000 and he burns it up dies
mama's left with no money and if you
don't have long-term care insurance
that's what you are left with that's the
normal scenario so that's why you get
nursing home insurance but the good news
is again the average stay is two point
four years that's the average stay and
you know you can learn more about it at
Dave Ramsey comm just click on ELP for
long term care insurance and that you
meet with somebody in your area sit down
talk to somebody they'll shop help you
find it and learn learn learn learn
learn learn but that's the basics and
and some of you need that there's a
weird thing about nursing homes the
people have it's strange
in their minds there's two things that
are weird thing one that's weird is they
say well you know we've got to move on
daddy and Mama's money out of their name
because the nursing homes gonna get it
all well that's weird for several
reasons one is it kind of says that you
don't think that nursing homes deserve
to be paid you go to a restaurant eat
their food you expect to pay the bill
you go to a car lot and leave with one
of their cars you expect to pay for it
why is it you don't think you pay for
nursing home the nursing home took all
our money no you bought their services
they didn't take all your Europe it's
funny how people the words they use to
describe nursing don't care and by the
way you can't move money on a mom and
daddy
name in order for them to get
government-provided nursing home care
government provided nursing home care is
welfare it's for poor people and if you
intentionally make someone poor who's
not poor by moving the money out of
their name that's called fraud
it's called welfare fraud and the
government has the ability on Medicaid
provided nursing home which is welfare
to look back five years and see if you
move the house out of their name move
the money out of their name in order to
qualify
that's like saying I'm not gonna work so
I can get food stamps when I when I have
it or I'm gonna go get a job and I'm not
gonna report my income so that I can get
food stamps that would be called fraud
fraud criminal activity you get the idea
so I mean but somehow when it's with a
nursing home people who would never take
out welfare in a million years try to
arrange your way to get welfare that
they're not due and they would never
think about it that way they just think
that somehow like the nursing homes are
like walking around with a vacuum
cleaner sucking up people's money like
mysteriously stealing from you now
listen they don't take your money unless
you take their service a restaurant
doesn't take your money unless you eat
there and a car dealer doesn't take your
money unless you take a car from there
it's the same way it's it's a purchase
of a good or a service as all it is
that's the process that you're facing so
that's the thing to think about is
you're looking at nursing home so
long-term care before age 60 I do not
recommend it I'm 57 I do not have it I
do not recommend it the percentage of
people who spend time in a nursing home
is less than 1/2 of 1% prior to age 60
and I would not insure that but after
age 60 the numbers go up every second
it's crazy how the statistics change on
that